the latest on the new covet wave
spreading across the country the cdc is
under fire for what many consider to be
confusing advice on how to handle the
surge the agency recently changed the
number of days that people with symptoms
should self-isolate they dropped it from
10 days to 5. it initially said that
people do not need to be tested before
leaving isolation but the cdc has since
changed that and the current guidance is
that if someone has a test and wants to
test an antigen test on the fifth day is
the best approach
just before new year's cdc director dr
rochelle wielinski told us here at cbs
mornings why there was initial
hesitation about those antigen tests
because we don't know how this antigen
performs with regard to predicting
transmissibility towards the end of your
period of infection we know it performs
really well during that period where
you're initially infected but the fda
has not at all looked at whether that
correlate of your positive antigen
really does correlate with whether
you're transmissible or not
and cdc director dr rochelle wolinski
joins us now live dr wilinski good
morning to you thank you for being here
confusion seems to be the word of the
day uh could you help us understand
what has changed in terms of what you're
looking at to make these recommendations
shift ever so slightly from the cdc
yeah first let me just say sort of where
we are and that is we have a lot of
cases out there and we believe 95
percent of them now are omicron we know
that our hospitals are filling up and
they're filling up with people who are
unvaccinated 17 times more likely to be
in the hospital if you're unvaccinated
compared to if you're boosted so first i
want to say get yourself vaccinated get
yourself boosted with regard to our
isolation guidance i remind you
isolation is for people who have had a
positive test and we have now dozens of
papers that are now on our cdc website
site that we've reviewed to update this
guidance in the context of the science
and the epidemiology of our time so what
we know is that for the one to two days
prior to your infection and the two to
three days after your symptoms you are
maximally infectious that's when your
biggest infectious and contagious period
is by day five after your symptoms most
of that infectiousness that
contagiousness is really behind you and
that's really where we say
do you have symptoms if your symptoms
are better you're safe to go out as long
as you're wearing a mask all the time
now what we heard over the last week is
many people were interested in using an
antigen test they had access to the
antigen test so we did not pivot our
recommendations what we did is we
provided guidance for how you'd use and
interpret that antigen test if you so
choose chose to take the extra step to
get one and that is if it's positive
stay home and if it's negative please
continue to wear your mask because that
does not mean you're no longer
infectious
the the word access if you have access
to is an unusual word defined in a
medical or scientific recommendation it
makes me wonder and a lot of people have
been wondering if tests were widely
available if access was no object would
the recommendation or in fact the policy
to make it a little bit harder line from
the cdcb yes test required before
leaving isolation
you know we require tests for leaving
quarantine quarantine being those period
period of time after you've been exposed
um what i do want to say is that we have
to provide guidance that is
you know grounded in science that is
grounded in the epidemiology of our
current moment in time and implementable
at
the state and local jurisdictional level
so if people on the fifth day of a
positive test they've been isolating if
they do not have access to a test
uh and they're they're not exact they
want comfort in going back out there in
society they don't want to spread this
thing what's your recommendation to them
if they can't get a test they should
stay indoors
if they can't get a test they should
wear a mask and that's actually really
what our guidance says isolate for those
first five days after those first five
days make sure you're feeling better if
you're feeling better then you really
can go out but you need to go out and
you need to be wearing your mask all the
time so what does that mean it means
don't go
joining lunch rooms with your colleagues
because you have to take your mask off
to eat don't go to restaurants don't go
to gyms where you might take your mask
off to exercise don't go visit your
immunocompromised or elderly family
because those last five days you still
may have a little bit of infectiousness
in you we want to make sure you're
wearing your mask all the time
yeah dr olinsky i know the cdc is
balancing safety with practicality uh
trying to get people back to their
normal lives while also keeping people
from from contracting covet
you've got a lot of criticism in the
last week uh people said you've been
confusing
any shortcomings you want to acknowledge
i mean what do you say to those critics
you know we as i said we're working 24 7
12 000 people to keep america safe to
update our guidance in the context of
really fast moving science and really
fast-moving epidemiology we have room we
can improve in our communications of how
we convey that science to the american
people we will continue to do so we've
gotten some criticism but we've also
gotten quite a bit of endorsement of
these new guidance
yeah and a lot of people feel really
good about a five-day isolation because
isolation is difficult on a human being
dr welinski thank you very much we
appreciate you coming back to clarify
thank you so much tony